- Life is like a bunch of Korean snacks,
you never know what you're
eating 'till you open it.
(upbeat music)
- It feels like Harry Potter having
Bertie Bott beans for the first time.
- This is the first time I'm like,
"Oh, yeah, Korean food."
- Korean food for me would be,
anything that has fins,
or anything under the ocean.
- If it says fun and yum on the packet,
it has to be fun and yum, right?
- That's (beep) good.
- A little bland.
- Very bland.
- There's no masala, there's no taste.
- It tastes a little bit
like nothing, really.
- I don't generally like seafood,
but this is pretty tasty.
- It's like just having fried flour.
- This is peanut balls.
And this is peanut balls icy.
- How do you even know that?
- Because it says right here in English.
- It is sweet on the inside.
So I dunno why you call it spicy.
- In India you get a peanut snack,
then a spicy snack separately.
But this is like--
- Mashed together.
- It does the fusion
dance and mashes together,
and then you get Korean food.
- So among the two,
I think that I can keep
on having for a long time.
- Yeah, this is definitely better.
- Not spicy, but the best flavor.
- You know Sean,
this is like one of those chocolates
when you eat them, you
think it's really good,
but after two bites you
don't wanna eat them.
- We have crunchy rice rolls here,
which look a bit like
Rice Krispies Cereal Bars.
Tastes exactly like Rice Krispies.
Again, tasteless, it just has
a little hint of sweetness,
and that's it.
- I didn't really love
it, or I didn't hate it,
it was fine, I could eat it.
- Very mild and very light,
it's a good, sweet way to end a meal.
- I would like to draw your
attention to the fact that
a kancho sample choco biscuit
winks very suggestively at the user.
- They know what they're doing.
They get all loaded with sugary stuff,
like Indian and American snacks.
- So it's chocolate inside a biscuit,
and then you bite into it,
and the chocolate oozes out!
- Dude, none of that happened for me.
- I love all of it, I mean--
- Really, how?
- Yeah, I did love it!
- I liked it, most of it.
- The magic formula is, when in doubt,
add two hundred grams of red chili powder.
Which I think should be followed.
(upbeat music)